- Welcome back!
- I'm so happy to be here.
- Go ahead. Go ahead.
- Hi rad moms. Wow.
- Go ahead. It's all
right. It's all right.
Do you get that just
when you enter Target,
like you go and people
are just like, "Woo!"
- I wish.
- So wait, do you get into Christmas?
- Oh, I love, love Christmas.
It is my favorite holiday.
- Me too.
- I love it.
And we usually spend Christmas in Hawaii.
- Which is kind of different because I,
not very snowy.
- Not very snowy, but nice.
It's where Barack is from. So
that's where his family is.
And because it's so far away,
it's really the time we
get to spend with them.
So it's become a tradition.
- I love Hawaii.
Do you love Hawaii?
- I mean, that was half
the reason why I said yes.
(crowd laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- What was-
- Like, in laws. Beach. Sun.
I was like, "I think I love you."
- Got lucky there.
So wait, before the show we
asked our rad mom viewers
if they had any questions for Mrs. Obama.
So let's do one of those right now.
So Alicia from Minneapolis
asks, "Before we had kids,
my husband and I agreed to
share the work," (chuckles)
oh, sorry. (laughs)
"To share the work of parenting 50/50."
- Oh see, we all laughed.
You could barely even get that out.
Like ha ha ha. Silly men.
- "Both of us have careers.
Let me tell you, it's
70/30 on a good day."
I think you're winning.
"I realize this man will
probably never change,
which is frustrating because
he's truly a good dad
and husband."
What is your advice on how to manage
my feelings about this?"
I feel like we should just
send her Elsa singing,
"Let it Go."
(all laughing)
'Cause like, you know what?
- But that's great.
You know, that's great advice.
We have all been through it.
That whole 50/50, I
write in the book about-
- That doesn't exist I don't think.
- It doesn't exist.
And it's not realistic.
What I would say is-
- You're busier at different times too.
- Exactly. I mean has it
been 50/50 in moments?
No. Has it been 50/50
for me over 30 years?
Yes. It balances out.
- Ooh, I like that. Yeah.
- So what my advice would be,
make sure you are taking care
of yourself, you know, because
that's the thing that we do.
Sometimes we take on more
because we feel guilty when we go work out
or when we go to the hairdresser.
And we also don't trust him
with our kids, you know?
- Will they arrive in tact
without a broken bone?
- So we have to, like you said, let it go.
My advice, when I stopped
resenting my husband for that,
was when I started prioritizing myself,
and I didn't wait for him.
So the help I learned didn't
have to come from him,
but I needed it.
So I relied on my mom and my girlfriends
and a broader community of
people to give me that break
so that I'm not so mad
at him all the time.
- I think that that's
good too though as well
because a village is
raising my kids with me.
You know, whether it's
grandma, whether it's my,
you know, sister, whether it's my nanny,
whether it's my people
around me, my friends.
Like I think a village is-
- Why we've gotten out of
that habit, that notion.
We're making moms feel like they have
to do it all.
- Do everything, yeah.
- And it was never like that.
I mean we're really the first generation
of the nuclear family.
It's just like me, my husband and my kids,
or my partner and my kids.
That was never the case.
I was raised in community.
I was raised with a great-aunt downstairs.
- I was raised in daycare.
- Grandparents around
the corner.
- Yeah.
- You know, you have to rely
on a community of people
to make it happen.
That's the way you raise good kids,
and they get benefit from being
exposed to different people.
Different, you know, approaches.
- Find more independence.
- Exactly.
So don't try to do it
on your own, you know?
Do it with him.
Get his 30 and get the
other 50 from other people.
- And then listen to
"Let it Go" in your head.
Her new book is called
"The Light We Carry."
So you've referred to your new
book as a toolbox of sorts,
which the only place I've
ever heard this is either
at my kids' school, it's a
great school my kids go to,
or in therapy because
it's something for, yeah,
because it's something
for your toolbox to learn.
It's like, obviously I
haven't learned this lesson
'cause it keeps hitting me in the face.
Like, what does it mean
for you? Like a toolbox.
What does that mean?
- For me, it's just the habits
and practices that I've accumulated
over the course of my 58 years of life
that get me through
uncertainty and tough times,
which we have all been going through.
And I get asked a lot
as a former first lady,
as somebody who's out
there as a public figure
as I assure you are,
especially from young people,
"How do I find my voice?"
You know,
"How am I seen?"
- Because sometimes you're
afraid to say something.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Exactly. People wanna know
how do you find a good partner?
How do I parent?
This book is my offering.
But I also want this to
be, this book to lead
to a conversation of other mothers, women,
people sharing how they get through
because uncertainty is baked
into the human experience.
And I think too much
time is spent trying not
to feel anxious or feel uncertainty.
- Filter yourself,
like an Instagram.
- To filter yourself.
When the truth is you gotta just lean
into the fact that that's part of life.
So now, how do we figure
out how to manage it?
You know, how do we get
through without falling apart?
- I love what you just said too,
'cause I feel like it's kind
of a dedication in the book
that ignited the light in you, right?
I feel like that's what
you're trying to do
for others is ignite their light.
- And everybody has that light.
And I think in times like
this where we feel divided
and the messaging out there is negative,
we start to think there's
no light out there.
But my experience as the
former first lady living
in this country is everybody's
got that light, you know?
And over time, it's either fueled,
especially when we're kids.
It's fueled by love and
support and investment.
Or it can be slowly snuffed out by hatred
and bigotry and lack of-
- You just get beaten down.
- They just get beaten down.
But the light is there. It's in all of us.
- I feel like too, it's about small things
because I feel like the
world can be overwhelming.
Even like this show,
we have such a stage to
help so many people, but
it can be overwhelming.
There's so much need.
There's so many people
doing amazing things.
But it can get overwhelming.
Especially watching the news
can be very just soul crushing.
- It could be paralyzing.
- Yeah. Just soul crushing.
And you're like, you
kind of feel hopeless.
But I feel like it's the small things
and I feel like you
touch on this too, right?
- It's one of the chapters,
it's called The Power of Small.
- The small little ripples-
- I give that advice to a lot
of young kids who feel
overwhelmed by the bigness
of the problems we're
facing and they're facing.
What I've learned to do
is to control what I can.
And throughout the stages of my life,
that power and control
has varied, you know?
What I was able to control
at 15 is very different
from what I can control
as the first lady of the United States.
But what I could do was
what I had control over.
And sometimes that helps us to prevent
from making great the enemy of the good.
Sometimes if we feel like
we can't fix everything
then we feel like we
shouldn't do anything at all.
And I don't want young
people to get burned out
especially as they're thinking
about big problems like climate change
and criminal justice and
racism and global economy.
It's like-
- That's what I'm saying.
It could be overwhelming.
But maybe find a focus.
- You're 15, you know?
If you're 15, your focus should be school.
You know, do your homework.
That's what you can control.
You know, don't bite off so much
before you have the ability
to really handle it.
So there's a whole chapter on that.
That's an important tool of mine.
Even in my position, I
stay hopeful because I look
at the thing right in front
of me that I can actually do.
You know, we can't fix climate change
if we're not gonna vote.
And voting is that small
thing that we all control.
- [Kelly] It's a big thing.
- That is a big thing.
That's the power of how small it is.
- [Kelly] Power of the people. Absolutely.
(crowd cheers)
So in this new book,
you say your girls are in the
flea market stage of life.
So what is that?
- That's a metaphor also for watching
your adult children start to
create home for themselves.
- Yeah.
- So we went by their apartment,
Barack and I, for cocktails before dinner.
- Oh my gosh!
- And they had made a
couple of weak martinis,
which I was glad to know
they didn't really know how
to make martinis.
- Like, did you put alcohol in it?
- Yeah, yeah. It was bad.
But it was a good effort. Good effort.
So they had the nerve to
then as we put down drinks
and be like, "Let me get a coaster."
And I was like, oh, all of a sudden-
- Oh, do we care about rings right now?
- We care about coasters.
You care about your
little $4 coffee table.
- I know.
- You know?
You didn't care about
coasters in the White House
for all eight years.
I didn't see you rushing
to protect that antique
surface.
- It's so true.
'Cause I started making my kids,
I take 'em to Target, I'm like,
"I'm gonna show you what toys
cost 'cause you're unaware."
So I make them and I said, oh,
they're like, "We have
$20, let's go get it."
And I go, "Yeah, let's go with your $20
and see what you're gonna get."
And they were so disappointed,
because everything is so expensive.
And I'm like, welcome.
- That's their whole, you
know, they're very cheap now
with their own money, which I appreciate.
- With ours though, they're not.
With my wallet, they're fine. (laughs)
- That's right. That's right.
So, you know, cobbling
together an apartment,
building a life, creating
their own friendships,
watching them build their own community,
it's like, better than I expected.
I mean, I miss having them with me,
but just watching them become real people
in the world and doing okay-
- [Kelly] And adulting.
- Adulting as they say. It's like-
- I can't imagine my kids,
like they're six and eight so.
- And you know, you don't need
to, they're not ready yet.
- [Kelly] The world isn't ready yet.
- They're not ready yet.
That's why they're with you.
- Another thing that a
lot of us mamas deal with
is making friends as an adult.
- Yeah.
- And I love that you refer to this.
Is it the kitchen table?
- [Michelle] Yeah.
- So what is, explain
what the kitchen table.
I love this. That's cool.
- I call it the kitchen
table because growing up
everything happened in
the kitchen, you know?
- Yeah.
- Because you come to your kitchen table
for safety and love and security, right?
So I called it that.
But for me, it's my friendship
group outside of my family.
I still have my mom, my family crew.
But we particularly as women,
I find that my kitchen table,
those are the other people that stop me
from being mad at the 30%
my husband is giving me.
Because they're stepping up
and giving me what he cannot.
And I want my girls to practice
developing a kitchen table.
That's a tool. The kitchen
table is a tool, right?
And I experienced that as first lady.
I mean, I had to make
new friends because I
was still a mother raising kids.
And rad moms know, you've
got to have mother friends
in the school.
- Yeah.
- So I had to step out.
Nobody was gonna come up to me, you know?
You couldn't even get
near me with security.
- I was like, they're
probably scared. (laughs)
- They were, yeah, they
were probably scared.
So I tell the story of
the first time I set
up a play date for Sasha,
because I just had to find a mother that I
thought I wanted to meet.
- I just love that
you're doing a play date.
- We set up a play date.
- I can't imagine that call.
- She is now a good friend of mine,
but at first I just
saw her and I was like,
"Why don't you have
little Olivia come over?"
And of course she was like, "Sure!"
And so she, later as we
became friends, she told me
the story of what it was
like coming to pick Olivia up
after that, coming to the White House,
which you know,
what is on the other
side of being my friend?
Well, it is a social security check.
It's, you know-
- Background check.
- It's a clear vet before you
can even come in the gate.
Not to mention she wasn't
even coming in the house,
but she went and got her
hair done, her nails done,
washed her car.
- She was like, "Yeah!"
- She was like,
"I am not showing up
messy at the White House."
And so she pulls in and I decide outside
of protocol that I'm
gonna take little Olivia
down to the south lawn.
Which you do not leave the
residence as a principal
because it sets off all
this outside security.
The counter assault team
goes into action high gear.
- Oh my God.
- Black flack jackets
with machine guns, dogs,
they start descending.
- Yeah.
- So here I come.
Her car is now surrounded by security.
I step out into the south lawn
with little Olivia and I'm
like, "Get out. Come on out."
But she had been explicitly told,
"Under no circumstances, ma'am, are you to
get out of your car."
- This woman is about to
pee her pants.
- So I'm calling her.
I'm like, "Get out."
And she's like (groans).
So she slowly gets out to carefully,
and we have a great chat.
She played it all off. I
didn't know any of this.
So I'm retelling her story.
- Oh, this is a nice woman.
- And she is now one of my best friends.
Olivia's like a daughter to me, you know?
Lo and behold a new daisy popped up
and it is a beautiful thing.
And if I hadn't taken
the risk to extend myself
and to reach out to a stranger, you know,
and make a friend, she
wouldn't be in my life.
And so if I can make new
friends, anybody can, all right?
- 'Cause there's people that, (laughs)
oh my God, we need another break.
But first, Mrs. Obama brought
an early Christmas gift
for everyone here.
You are all going home
with a copy of her new book
"The Light We Carry."
(audience cheers)